so one of the most important sort of
components of social democracy was which
is the political ideology that I'm most
aligned with is that we see certain
areas of life certain areas of an
economy as deserving of being outside of
the for-profit system social democracy
is capitalism but it is capitalism with
limits it's capitalism with the fruits
of that system reinvested significantly
in making sure that no one Falls too low
in terms of their status in in the world
in the economy in in society and there
are certain areas that often come up as
deserving to be outside of that
for-profit system health care is very
often one education is very often one
and one that has been more discussed
lately but but less frequently is doing
something about housing how should we
deal with housing and with so much
negative news like a lot of the stuff
we're talking about is bad things that
have happened I have today just a really
great policy proposal to discuss from
Bernie Sanders relating to housing it
says housing for all plan that he
released yesterday and there's a view
about housing that is we should totally
decommodification
the rental value of properties so that
people can still own private property
we're not saying no more ownership of
private property real estate that that
being but seeking rent on property will
be pointless because whatever amount of
rent you earn you will have to pay a
land value tax equivalent to that now
potentially you would still get the
value of owning the property but you
would get that either way now there are
also that made that understandably will
sound extreme to some people in the
audience there are less extreme versions
than totally socializing ownership a
real estate of all housing and the truth
is that if you hear me talking about
this and you say David you're not going
far enough we should dica modify all
housing and put a land value tax
equivalent to the rental value of any
property that's not going to happen
anytime soon I think most people would
agree whether you like
or not that's a debate but it's not
happening anytime soon so the the
immediate thing that we should look at
doing is what is actually doable which
is socially democratic programs that
will seriously deal with homelessness
and the rising cost of living across the
United States Bernie Sanders has now
released such a proposal and it's a very
solid one and I want to talk about it
with you today the premise is that we
have a situation where it's frankly
outrageous that we have homelessness in
the United States we're a rich country
now we have the money financially we can
end homelessness in the United States we
should consider homes a place to live a
right cost of living is out of control
rent seeking and gentrification at the
hands of wealthy developers and
landowners and rich people it hurts so
many people and Bernie Sanders plan
deals with a lot of this now I'm just
gonna give you some of the highlights I
know some people will say I missed some
important elements of this there are
more than 30 provisions but I want to
focus on some of the important ones from
Bernie's housing for all proposal there
will be one nearly one and a half
trillion dollars spent over 10 years to
build and renovate nearly
seven-and-a-half million affordable
housing units in mixed income
developments as well as four hundred
billion dollars for two million mixed
income social housing units for
desegregation and integration Boston
actually does some of this where
affordable housing units are placed the
you might have a 12 unit development and
a certain number of those are designated
affordable which helps to integrate
rather than segregate people on the
basis of income it's not perfect but it
does do that to a great degree Bernie
would expand USDA section five one five
by five hundred million dollars to build
affordable units in rural areas as well
as protect affordable units existing
affordable units very important you know
we talked about how can Democrats appeal
to rural voters I'm going to deal with
this more on tomorrow's show as well
this is a great idea to go along those
lines Indian housing block grants will
be increased to three billion dollars in
total funding there will be seventy
billion dollars allocated to repair and
update public housing including
high-speed broadband which is in
port and we've talked about broadband as
a having it versus not having it is is
increasingly a segregating factor
economically the Faircloth amendment
will be repealed that amendment prevents
building new public housing in certain
situations via GND we were the green New
Deal that is there will be the
electrification and decarbonisation of
public housing which is both good for
the climate and also good for the people
who are in public housing a section 8
rental assistance will be fully funded
at the rate of four hundred and ten
billion dollars over ten years makes
sense there will be a strengthening of
the Fair Housing Act and the addition of
a non-discrimination law this small area
fair market rent rule will be expanded
and there will be two billion dollars
via the USDA combined with six billion
dollars via HUD for a first-time
homebuyer program first-time homebuyer
programs have existed for a long time
but the idea is let's increase it let's
strengthen it in order to deal with the
high cost of living that still keeps
people who are just a little bit too
wealthy to qualify for some of these
programs from buying we can enable them
to become first-time homebuyers as well
and then end the mass sale of mortgages
to Wall Street this is something a lot
of people don't even know happens but
very often there are lots of banks who
you will take out a mortgage with them
and very soon thereafter they will sell
the mortgage to a big Wall Street firm
this is an extraordinarily speculative
activity it doesn't benefit the consumer
and many people don't even know it
happens because often the originating
bank will continue servicing the loan so
what's what's not often discussed and
may not be obvious to those slamming
Bernie for wanting to quote spend your
money with a proposal like this because
people haven't earned it as we often
hear from right-wingers there's a
morality argument to make which is that
we are an extraordinarily rich country
ending homelessness is merely a matter
of deciding to end it not a matter of
having to figure out really complicated
ways to do what we know exactly how to
do it let's say you don't care about the
morality homelessness has insane
economic
costs that are quote socialized among
all of us homeless people are more
likely for a variety of reasons to end
up in the emergency room uninsured that
costs you money homeless people are more
likely to get arrested for marginal
crimes that are associated with
homelessness and that filled jails
costing us tax dollars it's it's we
could go into many examples of that and
we have but that costs you money
homeless people have more difficulty
finding jobs not having an address makes
it harder to find a job not having a
stable place to live makes it harder to
keep a job and to do well in that job
meaning that homeless people don't earn
wages meaning they don't pay taxes into
state and local governments which is not
good for any of us being homeless is
really expensive for society and
providing not just a home but I would
argue also medical care as we've talked
about for the last 10 years on the show
is cheaper for you in the long run if
you don't care about the morality of it
if you don't care about the people as
people then maybe you care about the
finances of it and it will save you
money to do something like what Bernie
Sanders is proposing here the other
financial thing here is that lots of
these components that Bernie proposes
are what we call demand side stimulus
construction energy retrofits service
providers of all kinds are involved
companies of all kinds are involved that
is an entire additional front of
economic stimulus that is in addition to
everything else that we're talking about
and so on all fronts this really makes
sense it's a great plan no plan is
perfect but I hope that other candidates
will develop similar plans and that if
we get a Democratic president replacing
Donald Trump that this is one of the
first things they deal with because it
will be good not only for the homeless
people that will directly benefit this
will be good for the economy this will
be good for neighborhood safety that
this will be good in every way that we
can imagine